[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend in allen das Schreiben vom
Energieversorger im Briefkasten sollte
man nicht ungelesen beiseite legen auch
wenn daran nichts angenehmes steht meist
sind es nämlich happige Preiserhöhungen
und immer stellen sich viele Fragen was
tun sollten denn nicht die Preis Bremsen
gelten vom Staat der reagiert jetzt weil
er ganz offenbar die Gefahr sieht dass
einzelne Anbieter die Gunst der Stunde
für enorme Abzocke nutzen nach dem Motto
wenn der Staat sowieso zahlt können wir
noch mal kräftig drauf schlagen per
Gesetz sollen überzogene Preiserhöhungen
jetzt für das kommende Jahr verboten
werden Frank Buchwald hat Details
Gas und Strom knapp und teuer viele
Wohnungen sind deshalb Kühler hohe
Preise aber treiben Verbrauchern
trotzdem Schweiß auf die Stirn nun soll
das Kartellamt den Versorgern auf die
Finger schauen mit den gesetzlichen
Regelungen wie sie jetzt eingebracht
wurden ins parlamentarische Verfahren
ist das Bundeskartellamt adressiert und
gut das ist natürlich auch eine Behörde
die tatsächlich die Möglichkeit hat
entsprechende kontrollaufsichten auch
auszuführen im November hat das Kabinett
die Strom und Gaspreis Bremse auf den
Weg gebracht darin auch eine Regelung
die Mitnahmeeffekte verhindern soll
deshalb müssen Versorger jetzt genau
nachweisen warum sie ihre Preise anheben
die Missbrauchskontrolle dient dazu
ungerechtfertigte Preiserhöhungen zu
unterbinden also solche die sich nicht
durch steigende Beschaffungskosten
rechtfertigen lassen wichtig ist aber
dass eine Kontrolle nicht zu einer
pauschalen Missbrauchs Unterstellung
führt weil diese Preiserhöhungen die wir
im Moment sehen sind wir haben ja einen
Grund und der Grund sind die ganz hohen
Beschaffungskosten am Energiemarkt die
die Unternehmen weitergeben müssen die
Beweislast liegt bei den Versorgern
Berlin müssen nun jedoch Tempo machen
verlangt die Opposition
das Kartellrecht muss geschärft werden
und die Bundesregierung muss dann dafür
sorgen dass diese Verfahren schnell
gehen wo es Beanstandungen gibt brauchen
die Verbraucher schnell Klarheit dafür
muss die Bundesregierung sorgen
gesetzliche Änderungen und
Verfahrensbeschleunigung muss Hand in
Hand gehen viele Stadtwerke schicken
ihren Kunden zum Jahresende
Preiserhöhungen ins Haus einige davon
könnten rechtswidrig sein es gibt
Preissteigerung es gibt starke
Preissteigerungen bei den Energiepreisen
deswegen unternehmen wir ja diese Gas
und strompreisbremsen und das ist
wichtig zu wissen dass es auch weiterhin
zu Preissteigerungen kommen kann
deswegen lohnt sich
Energieeinsparen und es lohnt sich auch
weiterhin darauf zu gucken ob es nicht
ein günstigeren Vertrag gibt Rat und
Hilfe finden Kunden außerdem bei den
Verbraucherzentralen das neue Gesetz
steckt in den parlamentarischen
Beratungen und soll wenn möglich im
Januar in Kraft treten
ja da sind noch viele Fragen zu klären
und es wird auch noch für wirbelsorgen
das kann man jetzt schon vorhersehen was
wir alle im kleinen merken gilt auch im
ganz großen das Geld ist nicht weg es
hat nur jemand anderes die einen leiden
unter unfassbaren kosten die anderen
machen unfassbare Gewinne 60 Dollar pro
Barrel Öl aus Russland mehr nicht das
soll jetzt die Obergrenze sein auf die
sich die wichtigsten Wirtschaftsnationen
dieser Welt inklusive der kompletten EU
geeinigt haben damit Russland nicht
immer weiter kräftig verdient und damit
seinen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
finanziert ob dieser massive Eingriff in
den Markt funktioniert ist offen das
ganze ist kompliziert und hat auch große
Risiken wie Florian neuhandzeigt
seit russische Panzer erstmals in die
Ukraine eindrangen hat die westliche
Welt auch dieses Problem jeder Euro
jeder Dollar für russische Energie
finanziert die russische Kriegsmaschine
seit mehr als neun Monaten genauso lang
versucht der Westen da auszusteigen es
geht in kleinen Schritten vorwärts wie
immer groß verkündet auf Twitter
today heute haben sich die Europäische
Union und die G7 Staaten darauf
verständigt einen globalen preisdeckel
auf über den Seeweg geliefertes
russisches Erdöl einzuführen das stärkt
die Wirkung unserer Sanktionen
die Sanktion das ist ein bereits vor
Monaten beschlossenes Öl embargo ab
Montag bekommt Europa kein russisches Öl
mehr über den Seeweg das Problem
Russland könnte daraufhin noch mehr
Kohle machen das Öl zu höheren Preisen
Richtung China oder Indien verkaufen und
hier setzt der neue preisdeckel an mehr
als die Hälfte der Öltanker weltweit
fehlt unter europäischer Flagge die
meisten der Geschäfte werden von
europäischen Firmen versichert ab Montag
soll beides nur noch gehen wenn Sie sich
an den neuen preisdeckel halten maximal
60 Dollar pro Barrel Öl das liegt knapp
unter dem aktuellen Marktpreis von 69
Dollar vor allem Polen hat er sich an
den niedrigeren Deckel gewünscht um
Russland empfindlich zu treffen nach der
Einigung Beton der Botschafter
wir verwenden einen dynamischen
Mechanismus der ölpreisdeckel wird immer
mindestens 5% unter dem aktuellen
Marktpreis liegen
und nun beobachter sprechen von einem
großen Experiment der Westen versucht
den Preis zu diktieren den andere für
russisches Öl bezahlen um so den
Weltmarkt zu entspannen wichtig vor
allem für Entwicklungs- und
Schwellenländer die unter den hohen
Energiekosten besonders leiden aus
Russland heißt es heute das Vorhaben sei
gefährlich noch aber ist offen wie die
russische Regierung auf den neuen
preisdeckel reagiert die entscheidende
Frage wird sein ob Russland am Montag
entscheidet
weiterhin zu liefern und sich auf diesen
preisdeckel einzulassen oder ob es die
Regierung es den Unternehmen verbietet
entsprechende Geschäfte unter diesem
preisdeckel zu tätigen wenn letzteres
passiert was ich für nicht
unwahrscheinlich halte wird der Ölpreis
wahrscheinlich doch eher steigen und so
ist dieser Ölpreis Deckel auch so etwas
wie eine Wette wer hat die Macht über
den weltweiten Ölpreis Russland oder der
Westen
Leben mit der Taschenlampe das ist Kiew
eine europäische Hauptstadt von rund 3
Millionen Menschen die in den
vergangenen Monaten bereits oft bewiesen
haben dass sie sich nicht unterkriegen
lassen in Bars und Restaurants haben sie
tapfer angefeuert gegen dauernden
Luftalarm raketeneinschläge auf den
Hauptstraßen wurden schnell wieder
repariert jetzt zeigt sich aber wie
schwer das Leben selbst in so einer
Stadt wird wenn der russische Terror das
Stromnetz trifft wenn die Versorgung mit
Wärme ausfällt mit Wasser und Handynetz
und niemand weiß was noch kommt Hannah
Hebestreit ist in Kiew
ist es auch noch so kalt die Gaukler
sind immer da auf dem Mai Darling Kiew
bemühen Sie sich um gute Stimmung sie
hoffen als Fotomotiv auf ein bisschen
Trinkgeld aber auch diese Clowns sind
tief traurig über das was Russen ihrem
Land gerade antun
wenn ich müde nach Hause komme und habe
dann kein Licht und keinen Strom ist das
schlimm ohne Energie kann ich ja wieder
kochen noch heizen wir haben jetzt -4
Grad der kühlt die Wohnung schon richtig
aus
die Warnung vor Gefahr aus der Luft
verbreitet hier keine Panik mehr nach
über neun Monaten Krieg gehört dieser
Ton offenbar zum Alltag
eine
Angst ich gucke zwar wo der nächste
Bunker ist aber was passiert eben nee
Angst habe ich nicht
ich habe schon ein bisschen Angst aber
ich glaube an unsere Stärke und dass wir
das alles überstehen werden
sie wollen sich hier leben so wenig wie
möglich von russlandsattacken
einschränken lassen auch weil sie
gelernt haben dass dem geheult der
Sirenen nicht oft tatsächliches Unheil
folgt dass sie jetzt aber häufig spüren
ist die Anfälligkeit ihrer schwer
beschädigten Energieversorgung
Musiker und Zuschauer sind Profis
geworden im Umgang mit Stromausfall dass
der irgendwie zur Kultur dazu gehört
wir haben sogar erlebt dass die Konzerte
Besucher dem Orchester im Licht der
Taschenlampe so intensiv gelauscht haben
dass sie in eine ganz eigene romantische
Stimmung gerieten sie waren richtig
traurig als die Lampen wieder anlegen
die Konzerte sind nicht ausgelastet
manche Zuschauer haben Angst oder können
keine Tickets buchen weil Strom und
Internet immer wieder ausfallen
trotzdem haben die Musiker bislang kein
einziges Konzert abgesagt
wir denken dass wir hier eine Art
Seelentherapie betreiben die Menschen
kommen gerne und lassen sich ablenken
von den großen Problemen die uns das
Schicksal gerade bereitet
jedes Kulturangebot findet in Kiew seine
Fans sie spielt auf einem alten
tischklavierstücke aus der Zeit des in
der Ukraine angesehenen Philosophen
heute vor 300 Jahren wurde er geboren
ein Museum zu seinen Ehren haben
russische Raketen im Mai zerstört
[Musik]
Romantik aus der Not geboren ein
beliebtes Café in Kiew hat jetzt zwei
Speisekarten hausgemachte Pasta wenn es
Strom gibt Joghurt mit Haferflocken wenn
der ausfällt typisch erfindungsreiches
mutiges Kiew
Hanna jetzt kommst du mit der
Nachrichtenübersicht und da schauen wir
zuerst auf China dass seine strengen
corona-auflagen weiter lockert so teilte
die Millionenmetropole schensen mit dass
keine negativen corona-tests mehr nötig
sein um Bus und Bahn zu nutzen Peking
soll am Montag folgen dort entfallen
schon jetzt die Nachweise für den Besuch
von Supermärkten oder Parks seitdem
vergangenen Wochenende kommt es in China
immer wieder zu Protesten gegen die
strikte pandemie-
nach den Anschlägen auf jüdische
Einrichtungen in Nordrhein-Westfalen hat
die Bundesanwaltschaft die Ermittlungen
übernommen ein Deutsch-Iraner sitzt
bereits in Untersuchungshaft er soll
einen Brandsatz auf eine an eine
Synagoge grenzende Schule geworfen haben
in derselben Nacht vor rund zwei Wochen
waren zudem mehrere Schüsse auf das
frühere rabbinarhaus der Alten Synagoge
in Essen abgegeben worden laut
Ermittlern wird geprüft ob die Taten in
einem Zusammenhang stehen
Schweden hat einen Mann in die Türkei
abgeschoben der dort als Mitglied der
PKK verurteilt worden war nach seiner
Ankunft in Istanbul wurde er laut der
staatlichen türkischen
Nachrichtenagentur Anadolu verhaftet die
Türkei blockiert seit Monaten den
NATO-Beitritt Schwedens und fordert die
Auslieferung von PKK Mitgliedern die
schwedische migrationsministerin malmers
denagart erklärte die Regierung habe mit
der Auslieferung des Mannes nichts zu
tun die Entscheidung hätten Behörden und
Gerichte gefällt
zum Wintersport da gab es heute einen
Podestplatz für Roman Rees beim Biathlon
Weltcup in Finnland der 29-Jährige wurde
über zehn Kilometer Dritter dank
fehlerfrei im Schießen und einer auch
läuferisch starken Leistung den sie
holte sich der Norweger Johannes tinjes
Böh und auf Rang 2 landete ebenfalls ein
Norweger Grenz
und hier jetzt der neueste Stand aus
Katar das junge US-Team ist draußen bei
der WM verloren gegen die Niederlande
deren nächster Gegner wurde heute abend
ermittelt und da wollte es einer noch
mal wissen der mit 35 beinahe schon
Fußball Opa ist in seinem tausendsten
Spiel als Profi führte Lionel Messi
seine Argentinier gegen Australien wie
das ausgegangen ist Michael Kreuz
wie so oft steht er im Fokus Lionel
Messi Argentiniens Superstar der
Unterschied Spieler aber die ersten 35
Minuten eher von Kampf geprägt denn von
spielerischer Leichtigkeit
doch dann kommt er dieser sein Moment
macallister auf utamandy dann Messi 1:0
in der 36 Minute ein typisches Messi Tor
flach präzise und nahezu unhaltbar
Messi zur Halbzeit gefeiert und
gefordert ist jetzt Australien doch
Keeper Matthew Ryan unter Druck der
Fehler und das 2:0 Julian Alvarez der
Torschütze
Australien kämpft trotzdem unverdrossen
weiter und hat Glück crack a Goodwin
Fernandes fest ab nur noch 2:1 nach 77
Minuten und in der Nachspielzeit ist
sogar der Ausgleich möglich aber cool
kann Martinez nicht bezwingen es bleibt
beim 2:1 Argentinien Messi im
Viertelfinale
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Samstag die
lauten 4 10 29 41 42 45 Superzahl 7 alle
Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr und jetzt
der Blick auf die Wetteraussichten
morgen kann es in einem Streifen von
Nordrhein-Westfalen bis nach Oberbayern
etwas Sonne geben sonst bleibt es meist
trüb an den Küsten und später auch am
Alpenrand sind Schauer dabei die
Temperatur steigt auf 0 bis 10 Grad die
nächsten Tage bleiben bei 0 bis 7 Grad
wechselhaft die Schneefallgrenze liegt
bei etwa 500 bis 800 Metern ein kleiner
Streifen Sonne wir nehmen alles was
kommt und von uns allen hier vielen Dank
für Ihr Interesse und gerne bis morgen
wir wünschen Ihnen noch einen angenehmen
Abend
[Musik]